we're kids all we look forward to is for
Santa Claus to show up in Christmas we
wake up early
can we open up the gifts you know what
the goal is eventually the goal is to
eventually become Santa Claus and go and
tell yourself you had a great year what
do you want what do you want to get
yourself so I'm being Santa Claus today
you are looking at my Santa Claus and
I'm debating on what's the next Ferrari
we're picking on did we get a four eight
eight look at that let's give that puppy
right there how beautiful that looks
we get a four eight eight do we get a
599 GTB that we get on FF do we get a
spider
my gosh look at that look at this blue
here look at the school here you guys
see the school
anyways hey I hope you're on your way
for being your own Santa Claus in 2017
say can go and get whatever toy you want
to get into fusion if you don't like
Ferraris you like lamb Louis go at it I
just kind of like Ferrari a lot more
because it's a lot more in demand and it
way takes a long time to do part of the
Ferrari family but gold become your own
Santa Claus in 2017